we've got a voicemail number it's two
one nine two david p we don't have a
voicemail today we actually today we
have an email i mentioned last week that
there are people pressuring me to change
the format of the show to an interview
only show and i said i think it wouldn't
be good for the show here's one email i
received and i got a lot of emails like
it this one's from Lissette who said
dear david regarding the discussion
about having an interview show versus a
news show if it were an interview only
show i would immediately cancel my
membership in patreon that said it's not
because i don't enjoy the interviews I
do enjoy most of them very much I'm
really pressed for time and I have to
work hard to listen to your show and
bonus show every day the main reason
that I listen is because I want to hear
independent insights on what's going on
the more I know the more I can talk to
others and help to affect change in
these trying to put it mildly times but
I wouldn't make the time for interviews
that I do that I do to hear your take
and analysis of the news what you said
about an interview format immediately
torpedoing the show sounds about right
to me
this was the consensus from people
saying listen David but most people the
format of the show is what has built you
the audience you have it would be
incredibly risky to say hey you know
what let's do a completely different
format altogether so for the time being
we're not doing any change in format but
we will explore mixing in other formats
for individual episodes we've got a
great bonus show today I'm out of time
to tell you what's on it but it's a good
one and we'll talk to you then